- So, we're gonna be handcuffed together
for the next 24 hours.
- What the hell is this?
(upbeat music)
So, a little backstory a
lot of people don't know
is we didn't grow up
in the same household,
so for us to have only really spent
as much as a summer or
a Christmas together,
we kind of keep in touch pretty well,
considering that gap in our lives.
But we come together,
and now we're handcuffed
together for an entire day.
I had just set up everything
I was gonna do for work
and you go, "We're out."
The gate clicker's in my car.
- Which means we have
to get out of this car?
- That means we have to get back out.
- And then back in?
- And then back in, yeah.
- So, I'm hungry.
- [Michael] Is it--
- Let's go get some food.
All right.
After that, we went to Chipotle.
(Michael laughs)
And then we get to
Chipotle and we're in line,
and this lady was like, "Oof, rough day?"
- It was only 45 minutes in.
- It's that bad.
- She could already see
it all over our faces.
- She could see what was happening!
- She completely,
I mean, but when you walk
into a food establishment
with handcuffs on--
- True.
- Something is off.
You can tell everybody
about the years of torment
that I put you through.
- So, we are actually half-siblings,
but I never got to see you very often,
and so I would always be
this close to you. (laughs)
- And when we got together,
because of that--
- I really,
I remember one time, you tried
to push me down the stairs.
- I won't deny that.
I also won't agree that that's true.
- But we went from Chipotle,
and then we went to Sephora.
Michael's girlfriend, Chhavi, was with us,
and she really wanted
to go to buy Sephora,
and I was like, "Hell
yeah, I'm down for it."
Mike is not feelin' this.
It'll be okay.
- But see, it's a lot--
- My place is there.
Outside the door, where it's
comfortable and there's air.
- I tapped out.
Chhavi wins, Chhavi definitely wins.
It's only been two hours
and this has been the
longest two hours of my life.
- Feels like it's been 20.
- When we were leaving
Sephora, Mike decided,
out of the blue, he needed to take a leak.
- I have to go to the bathroom.
I have to go now, and it's right there.
I'm not gonna lie to you,
it was kind of a spike pee.
At that point, we were already in Sephora,
(laughs) and I was just like,
- What?
- "I'm lettin' it rip."
- [Destinee] I'm talkin' bout,
I walked in there with like head down,
I was like, "Okay, I'm just
gonna look at my feet."
- And this one guy was like
starin' at you the whole time.
Like it kinda creeped me out.
He saw you walk in as he
was about to walk out,
and he was like, "No, I'm here for this."
- (laughs) And we went to the nail salon
and they were very accommodating.
- [Michael] They were.
- [Destinee] They gave us a pillow,
they gave him a stool to sit next to me.
- [Michael] They were very nice.
- They also said, "What
the hell are you doing?"
(both laugh)
- Yeah.
- Sorry.
- And we were kinda,
we were kinda good about
going back and forth.
- It'll be fine! (laughs)
Come on, let's go! (laughs)
Michael, come on, I'm serious!
(laughing) Mike, Mike, Mike!
Okay, okay, you win, you
win, you win, you win!
(Michael laughs)
- But then my blood sugar
started getting low.
I got real hungry.
- That was by the time we
got to the grocery store.
By the time we got to the grocery store,
he was just like, "I'm
ready to go, I'm hungry."
- And then we had to shop for
the food we were gonna eat.
- Yeah, and you should never
grocery shop on a hungry stomach.
- No, you shouldn't, but you know,
you have to do what you have to do
when you're handcuffed to your sister.
- This is what Mama made, are you,
do I need to call up
our mother and be like,
"Ragu isn't good enough for Michael?"
- [Michael] Is that what she uses?
- Yes!
- [Michael] For everything?
- For spaghetti!
- You asked me what I wanted to eat.
I said turkey meatballs, you said okay.
- No, you said meatballs,
and I was like, "Ooh, spaghetti
and meatballs, perfect."
Spaghetti and turkey gravy
meatballs does not sound good.
- First of all, the
recipe came recommended
from my friend who is a chef.
- But was it served with spaghetti?
- It's a meatball.
It's a meatball!
- No!
- First of all, I'm
handcuffed to you for 24 hours
and you can't give me two
tablespoons of turkey gravy
on my recipe?
- I asked what you wanted to
eat when we went to Chipotle.
- We cooked.
Key and Ryann came over
from Real Housewives.
- [Michael] They did.
- [Destinee] And we were tryin'
to cook your meatballs and spaghettis.
At first, it was nonsense and chaotic.
(Michael laughs)
But then, we figured like,
"You work that half of the kitchen,
"I work this half of the kitchen."
- [Michael] Yeah.
- [Destinee] And we kind of got it down.
Food!
- Hey!
- Wine, housewives.
(woman laughs)
(Destinee laughs)
So, we're done hosting for the night
and we have all of these dishes.
I say we just put 'em in the dishwasher.
- Great idea. (both laugh)
I was so physically drained.
And I ate a lot.
So when I finally laid down, it was over.
I was done.
So the snap that you got was like this
because that's how I sleep.
- Dude, I, did we snore?
(both laugh)
- My biggest thing going into this,
I was like, "Michael is
always late doing something."
- Hey, first of all--
- It's always something.
- I wouldn't say always.
- We were late coming here!
- We were handcuffed together!
You can't plan to start your day
like you normally start it,
except now you're handcuffed to a person
and have the same--
- You plan accordingly.
- The same amount of, exactly.
- You plan,
okay, we're not going back down this road.
- We're not doing that again.
- We're not going back down this road.
- Don't bring that up, stop being petty.
- [Destinee] You still
had to come to my job
and I went to your job.
- [Michael] Yes.
- [Destinee] So I had meetings
that you had to be sitting in.
- [Michael] That's pretty cool.
- [Destinee] Yeah?
- [Michael] It was.
It was cool sitting in
and kind of seeing how it looks in here,
and there's all kinds
of stuff going on, and--
- All right, so at the end of the--
- So (laughs) don't try to
snap while I'm snappin'.
- (laughing) I'm trying to,
I'm trying to do this for my job.
- Okay, it's all right, I'll let you go.
- [Destinee] Sorry, excuse me. (laughs)
- So we're roaming the BuzzFeed hallway
and I'm just gonna interrupt
the video that she's doing--
- Yes.
- With my Snap Story.
- I hope this is worth it for you.
- This is worth it for me.
- [Destinee] I hope this is worth it.
- I been handcuffed to
you for the entire day
and this is my will, okay?
(Destinee laughs)
You see this?
I can't believe we're really doing this.
- [Destinee] I felt the
same way going to your job.
Like it was really cool
getting to see what you do
and your side of things.
But the whole us being
fluid thing didn't work
when you were trying to deejay.
- No, it doesn't, because you
don't know those movements
and you don't know how
that whole situation works.
I move a lot, I move quickly.
- I definitely think this experience
has made me appreciate you more.
- Aw, that's sweet.
- Before, I was just like,
"Oh yeah, this is my brother."
I see that you have like
these different nuances
and mannerisms that make you you
that I didn't know were there before.
- And vice versa, you know.
You see that I get
aggressive when I'm hungry.
(Michael laughs)
But I also have a different
appreciation for you as well,
and I kind of also get to see, you know,
like what kind of woman you're becoming
as you're getting older
and starting your life
and starting your career.
- [Destinee] Aw!
- [Michael] So that's, it's cool
to see where you're at right now,
you know, where you're working.
- He does love me!
(Michael laughs)
Wouldn't do this again, though.
- No, never again.
- Wouldn't do this again.
- You can call that a dub.
- Are we done, 24 hours?
- [Man] Yes.
- All right, yes, absolutely.
- Let's do this.
- Absolutely, sis, I'm wonderful.
Thank you, I'm good, bye.
- Oh, yes!
Here you go.
- [Destinee] Free at last, free at last!
(dramatic music)
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)